passte clever so fressen seltenes hatte
ich vorher nie mit ihr bestimmt bescheid
egal so feldmann tauge
[Musik]
hallo liebe wir machen heute eine bts
torte und die bekommt meine schwägerin
sie mit 15 bekommt sie heute abend zum
nachmittag zum geburtstag ich muss sich
sputen ich wollte diese sie die aber
unbedingt für euch mit filmen weit
inspiration braucht und auch eine bts
torte backen möchte falls jemand dabei
ist denn ich weiß wer wts ist das ist
eine kate popband die machen musik und
gute laune zu bekommen
[Musik]
ich habe ein bisschen was vorbereitet
damit das video nicht so endlos lang ist
und dafür gibt es ja auch meine buck
schule bzw diese basic reihe da habe ich
zb meine bizkit bühne schon mal vor
gebacken ich schreibe euch alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben wie immer hier
unten in die infobox und da steht auch
wie viele zutaten nicht verwendet habe
und wie ich das ganze hier in meinen
zwei torten bringen gebacken habe und
was ich auch vorbereitet habt ist meine
buttercreme das ist einfach für die
schöne optik gleich ich mache gleich
auch noch mal seine mascarpone kind das
zeige ich euch auch weil es muss halt
sowohl geschmacklich als auch optisch
passen
[Musik]
die buttercreme habe ich wie gesagt
vorbereitet aber ich habe noch kein
keine geschmacksrichtung rhein gegeben
ihr könntet jetzt mal hinter extrakt
eingeben oder worauf ich richtig lust
hatte ist eine zitrone buttercreme und
dafür habe ich mitgemacht habe ich euch
auch abgefilmt gibt es auch im basic
rezept zu und zu fertigen buttercreme
gebe ich jetzt einfach noch mal
ordentlich lämmerhirt
verrührt das und dann kommt ihr auch
schon zur seite ich wollte euch nur
zeigen uns vorbereitet habe so einmal
ganz kurz unter werden
das war es schon ich geb dir kurz in den
kühlschrank weil die mit durch die
ganzen soft boxen hier doch so ein
bisschen weich ist wenn ihr sie zu
machen in den kühlschrank gibt dann geht
sie richtig fest dass es für später gut
wenn die torte eingestrichen ist aber
nicht für jetzt daher achtet bitte
darauf dass ihr buttercreme möglichst
auf zimmertemperatur lagert oder wie ich
jetzt mal kurz in den kühlschrank gibt
ich mache jetzt weiter mit der erfüllung
jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich okay
du hast du schon buttercreme gemacht
wofür denn jetzt noch mit creme ich bin
ja ein fan davon dass man die torte
schichtet mit einer richtig leckeren
kämen wie zb einer mascarpone sahne
creme die man ist ganz gerne mache ich
auch heute und außen rum kommt dann die
mutter kind lief auch sehr lecker
wichtig ist natürlich dieses lange
schlagen und womit ihr das automatisiert
und außen rum ist dann halt nochmal
dieses optischer auch da weil die
buttercreme wird noch mal anders fest
als so eine seine mascarpone creme man
möchte ja auch eine stabile torte haben
und eine die halt optisch ansprechend
ist so und ich gebe jetzt hier in meine
rührschüssel dann nämlich die
küchenmaschine aber ich sage ja auch
immer ihr könnt auch euer handrührgerät
verbinde nicht einmal kurz waren also
wenn ihr euer handrührgerät verwendet
dann brauche ich das alles zu zwei
minuten länger alles andere bleibt
gleich also macht euch da gar keinen
kopf ich gebe jetzt jemals capone rein
gleichkommt sagen damit dazu puderzucker
werde ich sieben falls da doch klümpchen
drin sind das weiß man ja manchmal und
diese mache ich eine vanillecreme also
außen kommt zitrone und innen vanille
und vielleicht mache ich sogar noch ein
paar schokostückchen rein also heute
wird alles so spontan gebacken
[Musik]
so die füllung ist jetzt fertig ich habe
noch gegen ende ein bisschen sahne fest
einrieseln lassen dann könnt ihr euch
sicher sein dass die creme auch wirklich
schön fest ist lagert sie gern bis zur
weiterverarbeitung im kühlschrank ich
mache jetzt aber weiter mit meinen böden
nenne ich möchte noch eine so ein paar
frucht einladen smoothie frucht einlagen
machen und zwar muss ich dafür erst mal
wissen wie viele böden ich herausbekomme
ich habe jetzt hier quasi zwei große
böden die werde ich jetzt ein tortenring
lösen und dann gucken entweder halbiere
ich sie nur oder wenn wir die böden zu
dick sind dann werde ich doch dritteln
und dann entscheide ich halt wie viele
händler angekommen werden genauso machen
[Musik]
hamza
biscuit boden resta essen ja geil ich
liebe dieses bizkit boden rezepte
lotterielos und arabisches
brotfladen bruma das praxistraining so
auffällig dass richtig los und ich bin
immer froh wenn reste übrig ich wollte
das fenster raus teil noch auf fotos
war es war richtig lecker womit man
jetzt weiter mit dem schluss die frucht
einen dadurch dass ich hier viel böden
habe brauche ich drei frucht eingang und
ich habe beim einkaufen gesehen man kann
das muss ich selber machen aber macht
euch einfach ich habe beim einkaufen
gesehen es gibt so rosam ist moniz und
so babyblau smoothies ich hol dir gleich
mal her und zeigt euch wie die frucht
anlage machen könnte so für die smoby
fortan lang habe ich jetzt hier den
recht rosaneri dann ist es doch keinen
wie blaubeuren türkis und dann habe ich
mir gedacht weil wir drei einen langen
machen strecke ich jetzt dieses rosa
glas mit ein bisschen milch mit der
hoffnung dass es dort es sieht gut aus
gleich wenn es wenn man es verrührt ist
es dann wirklich so richtig schön rosa
und die frucht anlage funktioniert indem
ihr da irgendetwas verwendet was das
ganze fest macht damit uns wirklich dann
in die torte schichten kann und dafür
benutzt ihr am besten agad ihnen das ist
diese packung hier ich gebe jetzt sagen
wir mal hier mit rose an ich gebe das
jetzt hier einmal in meine hochland
pfanne gibt dann also hätte es noch
ausgeschaltet gibt dann engagiere mit
dazu geführt dass dann wird erst der
herr eingeschaltet und danach lassen ist
zwei minuten dann spielen kochen und um
das einzufüllen benötigen wir einfach
nur ein bisschen frischhaltefolie man
nimmt ihr euch irgend etwas rundes ich
nehme da meint orten ringen habe ich 4
cm kleine eingestellt als die böden also
das mit 16 zentimeter die böden sind 20
und dann wird das gleich rein gefüllt
und im kühlschrank für das ganz schnell
fest das dauert wirklich nur zehn oder
15 und so macht ihr dann weiter bis ihr
alle drei frucht einen lang fertig habt
[Musik]
bei den fruchtbaren bisher nur darauf
achten dass diese zwei minuten erst auch
dann gelten sobald diese ganze masse
köchelt dann wirklich zwei minuten in
time a stellen und dann habt ihr quasi
die lehrkraft und ab 35 grad märkte das
ist immer fester wird ich hab jetzt für
zehn minuten in die kühlung getan also
weg mit tiefkühltruhe und das hat der
clio zehn minuten gedauert und schaut
mal komplett fest geworden und magazine
besteht halt aus eigener ist nichts vor
also nichts tierisches drin das ist
komplett vegan ihr könnt auch relative
benutzen aber viele sind halt fan von
magath ihn genauso wie ich ich würde
vorschlagen ich zeige euch auf einmal
wie ich das ganze geschichte die könnt
ihr gleich ganz einfach hier raus in die
frucht einlagen ihr könnt euch im
vorfeld gedanken machen welche farben
als erstes schichtet ich möchte so ein
bisschen mit dem türkisen anfangen dann
ins rosa hochgehen also nehme ich mir
jetzt hier zuallererst den ersten boden
eine schöne tortenplatte und ich mache
das immer so dass ich ein bisschen von
der saale mascarpone creme auf dem boden
streiche also erstmal wirklich nur ein
bisschen dann gebe ich die erste frucht
anlagen drauf das ist bei mir die
türkise und dann kommt noch mal eine
ordentliche menge von der sahne creme
drauf und damit ihr das alles schön
gerade habt könnt ihr euch zu hilfe noch
einen tortenring dem damit nämlich dem
in der größe xl weil die torte wird ein
bisschen her
[Musik]
wir haben die torte jetzt komplett
geschichte gibt einfach so gespannt auf
den anschnitt aber dass dem er später
ich film zwar nicht so professionell mit
sondern wahrscheinlich noch mit der
block kamera aber ich sag euch den
anstieg auf jeden fall auf dem
geburtstag ich mache jetzt folgendes ich
habe übrigens hier oben keine sahne
mascarpone creme mehr darüber gegeben
zum abschluss man mit ganz dünne schicht
buttercreme und wir machen das jetzt so
also ich mir mit erstmal den tortenring
ihr weg der sich hat einfach das alles
schön gerade gestartet wurde ihr könnt
wenn ihr euch unsicher seid oder wenn
eure seine mascarpone creme durch äußere
einflüsse wärme etc einfach noch zu
weiches könnt ihr das an der stelle auch
gerne für eine halbe stunde kühlen ich
habe gemerkt die creme ist schon sehr
fest ich muss da jetzt gerade noch
nichts kühlen daher mache ich indirekt
weiter da hab ich jetzt gerade mein
langes messer genommen war dann einmal
aussah richtig gut aus also ich muss
sagen toll toll toll es ist fast alles
gut denn ein fan hatte ich selbst für
tic toc gefilmt das verlange ich euch
unten in der infobox video wenn euch
diesen fall angucken möchte und dann
werde ich jetzt erstmal mit der
buttercreme dies noch nicht eingeführt
das machen wir gleich erst werde ich
jetzt hier außen erst mal dünn alles
ansprechen das hat den folgenden grund
wir wollen die krümel erst mal so ein
bisschen binden und da für mich jetzt
nicht dass sondern meine winkel palette
also erst mal nur ganz den einstreichen
krümel binden und dann die komplette
torte für 20 bis 30 minuten kühlen und
wir haben in der zwischenzeit die
restliche buttercreme 1
[Musik]
die erste buttercreme schicht ist schon
fest gewonnenes erkennt ihr daran dass
ihr halt anfassen können und nichts an
den fingern kleben bleibt und wir färben
jetzt die restliche buttercreme ein ich
möchte gern farbverlauf und zwar nehme
ich dann ein zartes blau flieger violett
und rosa da nehme ich mir einfach jetzt
die buttercreme lebt hier noch mal in
meine zwei weiteren schüsseln so ein
teil davon
und dann habe ich ein wenn ihr meine
lebensmittel verpassen verwendet die
sind extrem ergiebig und wir brauchen
wir einen hauch davon ich habe hier zb
azurblau wieder violett und brombeeren
oder mit ihr beschafft damit ihr
bescheid wisst welche ich verwende wie
gesagt bitte nur ein vip sich in der
welt ihr merken dass ich das sofort halt
in der gewünschten farbe einfärbt
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt die butter krems hier
einmal eingefüllt in spritzbeutel ich
nehme da einfach ein weg spritzbeutel
diesen aber so robust kann man
theoretisch gesehen auch auswaschen und
öfter verwenden und da stellte gleich
vorne einfach nur die spitze mit einer
schere und jetzt machen wir diesen
schönen raum bruck das heißt ich starte
jetzt hier mit diesem zarten blau vorne
bist weg steht und dann da müsst ihr
euch jetzt gar keine mühe geben geht ihr
einfach so am rand entlang macht so ich
glaube so zwei drei linien so dass ihr
dann gleich diesen farbwechsel habt dann
statt also da mache ich halt weiter mit
diesem rosa und gehe dann ins vieler
über oder umgekehrt ich koks recht
spontan auf jeden fall so dass es dann
nach oben hin ins zarte rosa geht
[Musik]
die komplett ein gestrichener torte muss
sitzen noch mal 30 minuten kühn aus dem
grund damit auch wieder in die
geschichte ein bisschen fester wird und
jetzt mache ich noch einen cache strip
drauf dann nehme ich meinen tag trip in
weiß falls sie den gerade nicht da haben
dort unbedingt schnell machen möchtet
dann schreibe ich euch unten infobox
auch was ihr als alternative vermischen
sollte damit ihr einen weißen kate
bekommt ihr könntet auch einer meiner
farbigen capes verwenden aber ich hätte
mir gedacht ich habe schon so viel farbe
drumherum also mache ich jetzt den
weißen grip da habe ich jetzt das ganze
schon in der mikrowelle erwärmt vorne
einfach so ein bisschen dran schrauben
dann habt ihr die perfekte öffnung und
dann einfach drauflos stücken und darauf
achten dass möglichst nicht den boden
berührt aber selbst wenn das auch kein
problem
[Musik]
beim trip habe ich jetzt drauf geachtet
dass ich nur noch so aus nun ganz dünnen
rand habe ich habe mit bewusst nicht die
ganze oberfläche mit dem grip voll
gemacht erstens kommt dann auch unser
cache top drauf dazu zähle ich euch
gleich was und zweitens komme sowieso
noch die kommt die restliche buttercreme
zum einsatz die habe ich mir auch
nochmal mit sprit füllen bereit gelegt
habe ich zum beispiel der französische
sterntaler eine rosen tülle eine normale
stellen natürlich verlinkt wie gesagt
alles unten infobox und ich würde es
gerne so unregelmäßig machen also gar
nicht so tapfer für tobacco stück
sondern einfach unregelmäßig und dafür
tue jetzt zuallererst meinen cake pops
auf die tor also in die torte rhein ist
das nicht wunderschön
guckt euch eines das nicht wunderschön
ich habe mir gedacht wie kann man das
jetzt so am einfachsten machen ich war
bei etsy ist einfach so eine seite da
kann man jetzt auch materielle sachen
oder nur so ok da gibt es finde ich süß
hamann on small business unterstützt
denn da hat jemand also denkt es
verschiedene keck top einfach bt escape
eingeben und da habe ich jetzt einfach
die noch 12 happy birthday unten drunter
steht ausgeschnitten danke sarah an der
stelle fürs schneiden hier papa noch
dahinter gemacht damit stabiler ist und
hier so cake pops stille mit was der
klever passte kleber so früh so seltenes
hatte ich vorher nie genug geredet jetzt
kommt der moment der momente und eine
tochter hat immer eine schönung eine
hässliche seite achtet darauf dass ihr
die schöne seite natürlich vorne haben
also was ich jetzt so ein bisschen
bemängeln würde ist dass der klub hat
doch sehr groß ist hätten am pc bisschen
kleiner ausdrucken können egal so fällst
mehr ins auge so und jetzt einfach nur
noch dekorieren dann war es auch schon
mit der torte ich würde mich jetzt
eigentlich schon verabschieden weil wir
werden den anschnitt nicht hier machen
sondern auch einen geburtstag ich nehme
wie gesagt die kamera mit zeigt euch da
ein bisschen was wünsche euch viel spaß
und nachmachen und hoffe dass euch das
video gefallen hat um ihm einen schönen
däumchen da last also bis zum nächsten
mal
[Musik]